what's going on guys you know what we've
got a VIP in the house so let's get
right to it
he is the screenwriter of Thor x-men
first class and the upcoming Power
Rangers film sextants Zach thank you for
being here sir well thank you and by the
way I co-authored all of those works
with my writing partner Ashley Edward
Miller I'm a screenwriter not a
screenwriter gotcha
Ashley Edward Miller we're calling you
out coming here and no you're welcome
anytime Ashley and we're big fans you
actually agreed to watch the honest
trailer with the creators of the Thor
honest trailer very excited about that I
am excited about that you see like
Michael Corleone II my hand isn't
shaking so um Zak uh Thor what kind of
pressure was there to be a part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and get that
right there was a lot of pressure but
the interesting thing is they already
knew at that point we're building
towards the Avengers they said guys if
you fail at everything else give us a
villain as good as magneto the thing
that made Loki so close to our heart as
a villain was that if you looked at the
events of Thor from his perspective he
was the hero he was the one who was
saving the kingdom from his hot-headed
brother who wasn't ready to his great
credit that was that was something that
that Kenneth Branagh was was very much
down with you know at the end of the day
what we always said we were doing is we
were telling a story about two boys who
both want their father to love them were
there any other mandates or just
thoughts from Marvel that we need this
to happen the problem that we kept
encountering is that Thor didn't really
have a force of opposition working
against him when he was on earth what we
were pushing was to have shield be the
force of opposition hmm and there was a
lot of skepticism from the Marvel people
at first because they were like well but
shielded the good guys and that was
something that they went from being
skeptical about to really getting on
board with at the time they were still
renegotiating Sam Jackson's contract and
we said well how about Coulson
he was he was really cool in the first
Iron Man movie is like he kind of popped
and you know we we ended up putting all
kinds of Easter eggs in like a you know
a sniper a shield sniper named Barton I
think what we're most proud of was the
fact that as we said going in there are
a lot of different ways of making a bad
Thor movie yeah there are only a couple
of ways of making a good Thor movie of
making something that's not ridiculous
in campy and like the golan-globus
Masters of the Universe moves yes um and
I'd like to think that we found one of
the good ways so Zach we're very excited
to watch the Thor honest trailer with
you but first I have to say it's been a
long strange trip getting you on a
winding road no I was you know I was
going for different 60s bands I like
better so uh you kind of got on our
radar with this tweet and I'll just read
it and we got okay
all right not to be too embarrassed okay
you shouldn't think it's you tweeted
fair warning if you link to one of these
insufferable honest trailers videos I
will unfollow you Wow I must have been
in a bad mood I was unfairly lumping you
guys together with some other people who
I will not will not mention by name here
and after I got in the dialogue with you
guys
ice I went back and watched a bunch of
watched a bunch of honest trailers ago
and what I what I realized about you
guys is that there is it's like yes you
take your shot sometimes but that
there's a real love for the material
behind that I'm so nice to hear you
saying is we are all fans and just huge
fans of this work so let's go ahead and
undo all that goodwill and watch the
honest trailer together okay I can't
wait Andi signor the creator lotta
traffic again Dan Merle the editor of
honest trailers I love the lake Spencer
Gilbert he is the writer hello I into
this honest trailer that says awkward
alright prepare
for a film that only exists sewn on
nerds will recognize the pawn guy in the
Avengers door you've seen great
superhero films you've seen terrible
superhero films now prepare for a
superhero film that's just kind of I
mean I guess they did the best they
could adapt ting a comic book about a
bratty space guard yeah I mean I kind of
said that was a tough job he's an idiot
demigod prince with a magical hammer
that really needs to buy a vowel Yaya
really no no ma'am yeah okay so you
gotta stop god I got a pause here yeah
kenneth branagh actually is like yelling
there it's like that's just hard to say
like can we meme it's something else but
the fanboys string me up if he did that
yes yes yeah okay we should be doing
that haha meet Loki Thor's evil
stepbrother who will stop at nothing to
betray his adopted father with the help
of his real father
in order to betray his real father to
impress his adopted father huh that
makes even less sense than his plan from
the Avengers not a plan what was Loki's
plan
Loki's plan all along was to was to
essentially lure the frost giants in and
kill them to impress Odin it's all about
impressing dad at the that he's the that
he's the war they want to be at the end
of the day I I would say the Avengers
plan where the third act consists of him
riding a jet ski um through Manhattan
while everyone else does the fighting um
you know I think ours compares pretty
favorably meet Odin Thor Loki's dad who
pretty much guarantees that one of his
kids will grow up to resent the other
only one of you can
to the throne both of you were born to
be king see this is all true we referred
to Auden as the Fred Sanford of the
Marvel University and that note
seriously he treats his sons not so well
and when one of them calls and Mohnish
he pretends to he feigns illness I'm
comin I'm gonna tell you one story
Thunder from Down Under
lo keem on the Godfather Idris elbow
Lord set from Power Rangers and
Portlandia doors obligatory movie so
Loki dies at the end it comes back to
life by the end of the credits that's
gotta be some kind of record what was
the end credits scene because that did
you help that as I've done after you
that was done after that was you weren't
exhaust might've I think Joss might have
directed that you know but it was always
going to you know it was always going to
end with with you know Loki seems to be
lost and then it's like oh no there is
well I just want to thank you for coming
for all cuts these again you the first
tweet was completely fair thank you for
looking us up and we're big fans and
were so gracious buted to the church yes
on astray again we light a soul I really
liked Oregon I did you you had a really
tough job of making that guy relatable
in the universe and you did a fantastic
job I absolutely guys what movie do you
want to see Zach Spencer right next uh
tell us in the comments section below
the best answer we'll send you screen
junkies t-shirt again I want to thank
you Zach hit them up on Twitter at music
music mus cz ACK
um it's a pun haha
oh yeah fantastic were thank you so much
thanks and brother thank you
um and thanks a nice ignored Admiral
Spencer Gilbert I'm Hal Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter thanks for watching bye
bye
oh oh okay uh oh
who are comfortable